Fake out, don't loop, cuz I fucked up.
My eyes were like, where's my scene?
I was like, where is it?
Where's my solo?
Where's my solo scene?
Fucking my brain is not okay right now.
I think like in four years, I have never like overslept a stream.
And like not even have a waiting room up.
I was not okay.
I was absolutely not okay.
So sorry guys, I'm so sorry.
Okay, so basically what happened is that I think Borderlands really fucked me up and...
Okay, watching the movie, I was so tired right after.
Like that took a lot of mental fortitude to get through Borderlands.
All the dragoons that were strong enough, all the dragoons that were trying so hard to be strong enough for Borderlands.
It fucked me up too.
Don't worry guys, it also fucked me up.
It was a wild ride.
It was such a bad movie.
I never realized how bad a movie could get until I watched Borderlands.
It's absolutely crazy.
For those who've never watched Borderlands, it is the most PG fucking movie for a game about guns, shooting, and killing.
Like for a game about all of that stuff.
Like the game is really well known for guns, shooting, and killing.
But yet there was no blood or anything.
It was very PG.
It was wild.
I'm like Borderlands is not a PG game.
Like I don't know how the fuck they were able to do all that for this movie.
But that made the movie incredibly mediocre.
It was so bad.
The casting was so bad too.
Thank you for the 5k subs.
Thank you, thank you.
Blake, welcome to the tomato farm.
Welcome, welcome.
So like right after the movie...
Okay, I would be surprised if we get a lot of people watching today.
Because people would be like, oh, I think she forgot.
I'm gonna go back to sleep.
Which is sort of like me where I was sleeping the entire time.
I...
Anyway...
Anyway, so...
That movie was the very first time I was like, maybe we should have a good movie next time.
Like we need to cleanse this.
Anyway, so...
I actually...
I actually like went to sleep right after the movie.
I was so tired.
I legitimately like just went...
Like I was like, alright, see you guys.
And I went straight to bed.
And I woke up at 11pm.
I woke up, I was like almost midnight.
I woke up like midnight technically.
Because it was like 11.45.
So like I woke up at midnight.
And I was like, oh my god.
I'm so tired.
I was like, I was like...
And I just stayed in bed for like, I think like an hour or two.
I was like, I'm just gonna relax an hour or two.
And then I'll get to work.
I'll get to work.
You're gonna go to work after this.
You have so much stuff to do.
And then like I stayed in bed for an hour.
But I was like, oh but the bed is so comfy.
The bed is so comfy.
So I think I stayed there for like an hour or two.
And then...
I fell back asleep.
And I woke up at like...
I woke up at like...
Well, and then my manager woke me up.
I was so confused.
You know like when you like...
You got wake up, woken up like suddenly.
And you're so like, where am I?
Like, who am I?
You're like...
You're like, where am I?
Who am I?
What the fuck is going on?
So I was just like, oh my god.
And then like my phone was ringing.
And then my manager was like, you have a stream!
And then I was like, oh my god.
It's 12.35!
And then the other thing is like, where are you?
You have a stream!
And I'm like, oh fuck, I'm sorry.
I'm so sorry.
I'm so fucked up right now.
I'm so fucked up.
Okay.
Alright.
This is gonna be TMI.
The reason why...
Because I was debating.
Do I talk about why I was so fucked up?
It's the time of my month.
Sadly, I'm a woman.
I got debuffed hard.
Okay, guys.
I'm getting debuffed right now.
So I'm sleeping a lot more.
Not the woman debuff.
Yes, unfortunately, this is the time where I'm reminded that I'm a woman.
And I'm like, no!
I'm not one of the boys today!
I'm like, no!
I can't be one of the boys!
I was lied.
Thank you for the Akasupa.
Thank you, thank you.
I can't think of anything funny to say.
So thanks for the last four years of laughs and good times.
Thank you for the Akasupa!
Not go cry in Marvel.
Thank you for the Akasupa.
Thank you, thank you.
No!
Broski's status lost for the day.
So like, now you understand why I was like fucking hibernation mode right now.
I'm not a real bro.
No way!
My bro's a woman?
How dare you lie to us like this?
Anyway.
So Zafia, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Wait, why is that?
Why you always choose to make us watch all these awful movies to make us suffer together when I'm already suffering anyway?
What's one more bad movie?
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Magic, thank you for the super chat.
As a Michi viewer, almost nothing is TMI.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Alright.
So yes, that's also why I was sleeping a lot.
Because I was just, you know, I'm so fucked up at the moment.
I'm very fucked up at the moment so I needed to sleep more.
So yeah, anyway.
So I hope the volume is a lot better now.
Just the volume is a lot better.
I'm sorry if the music was too loud that you couldn't hear me scream that I'm a woman.
Zero.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
So I fixed the volume.
We can blame the D.va for what happened yesterday.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Wait, could you guys sort of heard me in the beginning?
Even if the music was a little loud, were you guys still able to hear me?
Because the music guys were like, you should turn your music down.
You should turn the music down.
You're a woman!
Okay, welcome to the pro tomato farm.
Welcome, welcome.
That's why there was no waiting room or anything.
I had other stuff to worry about right now like to not fucking die from blood loss.
Speaking of that, I should drink some water soon to replenish my blood.
I'll be right back so I don't pass out.
Alright, enough about that.
Alright guys, enough about that.
I was like, the one time I let people know that I'm sadly not one of the boys today.
I got a fucking debuff of the month.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I'm not pro for today, Saj.
Darkblade, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I told you not to make us watch Borderlands.
I told you!
What is this fucking curse that you put upon me?
I can't believe it.
That's crazy.
Marco, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Speaking of blood, Doom and Ninja Gaiden both have sequels now.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Alright, so...
Today, we are gonna be playing Minecraft!
Let's see, let me make sure it's full screen.
I know people are like...
How do I do this?
So, this is Bedrock Edition, so I'm a little confused too.
I'm a little confused too.
I've never played Bedrock Edition before.
And apparently, it's a whole new world out there.
So, they just recently released...
This was back then, before I went indie.
I really wanted to play the Minecraft DLCs.
Because there was Spongebob, there was Disney.
At that time, I requested it and stuff like that.
But obviously, we couldn't because of firms.
Because they're like...
They're like...
There's like, you know, IPs and stuff.
And I really wanted to do the Disney one.
And the Sonic the Hedgehog.
There was all of that.
I was never able to.
And then, this week, they released...
They released the Sanrio Hello Kitty and Friends DLC for Minecraft.
And apparently, it's not just regular Minecraft.
It is...
There's like mini-games.
There's like mini-games in it.
So, like, for the Sanrio one...
Apparently, it's a farming game.
So, it's like basically a farming game with your Sanrio friends and stuff like that.
And so, I'm super excited.
I've never played Bedrock Edition before.
Well, to be fair, I don't play much Minecraft, too.
So, like, you know...
It's sort of like...
I just don't play a lot of Minecraft.
But, like, especially, I've never touched Bedrock.
And it's like...
You gotta...
There's like...
Oh, there's so many different things to it.
So, like, for the characters...
You can't use custom Minecraft skins.
You actually have to...
Pay for your skins.
Which is a little weird.
It's a little weird.
But, like, hey, you gotta farm the children somehow.
You know?
You gotta...
You gotta farm the kids for money somehow.
Yeah, so, like...
Wait, you can upload your skins?
Okay.
Wait, give me a sec.
Alright.
Is it here?
Create class?
Oh, that's place.
Oh, but then can I wear...
Can I wear clothes with custom skins, though?
Guys?
Can I, like, wear clothes with custom skins?
Chat?
Or, like...
No?
Like, in the...
Okay.
Now, you guys.
Alright.
Wait.
I can buy skins, though.
Alright, guys.
It's time to spend some...
Guys, it's time.
We're gonna spend my...
We're gonna spend some money.
It's time.
I'm in too deep.
Oh, my God.
I could be in a bad...
Alright, guys.
I'm already in too deep, guys.
We're gonna spend some...
What the hell?
There's...
Oh, my God.
What are all these skins?
Best-selling.
Ender...
Are you serious?
Skippity Toilet.
Oh, my God.
These are definitely for children.
The fact that, like...
Skippity...
Skippity Toilet is the best-selling Minecraft skin out there.
Oh, my God.
Okay.
Milo and Chip Friends Christmas.
Everything by Minecraft.
Oh, there's, like...
I, like, there's a whole category just for Star Wars.
What?
There's an entire category that's just for fucking Star Wars.
Okay.
All skin packs.
Alright.
What do we...
Should we...
Oh.
Bees.
Bees Teens.
Oh, my God, guys.
Let's go back.
Let's do high school roleplay.
Oh, my God.
Anime Slayers.
Wait.
Become a fierce and fearless warrior when you gear up in Anime Slayers skins.
Roleplay with friends in colorful robes and colorful hair and big anime eyes.
Okay, but, like...
Oh, my God, guys.
I could be anime.
These look so...
I could...
Oh, my God, guys.
I could be anime all night.
Oh, my God.
I could be babies.
What are these skins?
That's so kawaii.
Oh, my God.
They're cute.
They're, like, so kawaii.
Oh, desu ne?
I'm sorry.
I'm so sorry.
I'm cringing, too.
I'm so...
I'm so sorry.
It's me in charred anime.
Stop.
All right.
What else could I be?
Young Royals pastel.
What are these?
They're just...
Oh, my God.
I could be game.
I could be camo.
Look at the added eyes.
That's not even camo anymore.
All right.
I'm suffering.
Why are they all just teens?
What?
The rich royal family.
Free the squirrels.
Oh, my God.
Guys, I could be a gamer right now.
Guys, oh, my God.
Are you a gamer?
Ready up with your game merch and headset for an all-night gaming session.
Let's go.
Here.
Don't do that ever again.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Well, if you're in too deep already, thank you for the super chat.
Oh, my God.
Wait.
Okay.
These are actually really cute.
Okay, but I'm not a furry, but these are really cute.
I'm sorry.
But I like the...
Not the wolves.
I'm not talking about the wolves, guys.
I'm not talking about the wolves.
Oh, my God.
Oh, that cottage cat skin.
They're so cute.
You can't...
Okay, anyway.
Guys, I could be a gamer girl right now.
Guys.
Guys, what if I become a gamer girl right here?
This is where...
I could just be a gamer girl right now.
There's like...
There's Pat's style paradise.
I don't know what to be.
There's so many choices.
There's so...
Alan, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
You're never beating the furry allocations.
Mega, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Java players, check in here.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I know I should be playing the game, but I can't help it.
There's so many skins.
I like...
Which one do I get?
Guys.
I don't know.
Do I...
Okay, alright.
Here are the choices.
It's...
Oh, the millionaire roleplay.
How the fuck do I know if I'm a millionaire?
Like, is that it?
Is that...
Is it Barack Obama?
And tells that I'm a millionaire?
Like, how does...
How does this...
He's just...
Guys with big eyes.
How do...
How is that...
I'm a millionaire.
I don't understand.
We know what you are.
Black.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Not so Deadpool.
Doki, I can't lose to another Vtuber to the wolves.
Please.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Alright, guys.
Here are the choices.
Guys.
I either be anime skin or gamer girl.
Alright.
Those are our choices.
Doki, please.
There are so many.
Why?
Those...
Guys.
Okay.
Alright, guys.
There are two choices we have.
We're either anime girl, anime, anime, or gamer.
I'll make a poll.
I'm spending real hard-earned money for this.
Minecraft.
Sorry, I'm spending your hard-earned money.
Let me be more clear.
I'm spending all your hard-earned...
Wolf Teens.
Important correction.
Oh, my God.
Wait, I didn't know this was Wolf Teens.
The Wolf Teens are back, but this time in HD version.
Oh, my God.
What is...
Vampires and werewolves.
Okay.
Wait a second.
We might have a secret contender here.
Look at this.
The vampire and werewolves.
Okay.
But these are...
This is Wolf Teens.
Okay.
Secret surprise contenders.
Guys.
Oh, come on.
Okay.
Never mind.
These looked so much better.
I legitimately was like so excited.
I was like, oh, my God.
That looks like...
Oh, my God.
I won't be here.
And then it's like you open it and you're just like, oh.
That's...
I got clickbaited so hard.
I was so excited.
Oh, my God.
There's the pot.
There's...
There's the circus.
Oh.
Oh, my God.
I could be Poppy right now.
I could...
I...
Oh, my...
I could be Hasbun Hotel right now.
I could...
You know, you could get these skins.
You could get these skins for free in Java.
But, like, why get it for free in Java when I could pay these children your hard-earned money to be in Hasbun Hotel?
I...
MrBrokenBond, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Become the woman you were always meant to be, Toki.
Poor woman.
God.
MrBrokenBond, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Fistful, thank you for the super chat.
It was a bit late to stream, but I hope you're doing well.
Looking forward to the comfy times.
With Sadio characters, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Yeah.
I can't wait to start the game soon.
And, like, even though we've been doing...
We've been looking at skins for 20 minutes.
Oh, my God.
Dream+.
Do not give Dream more money.
The funny thing is that at least 1,000 children bought this pack.
At least...
At least 1,000 children bought this pack, too.
Because there's 1,000...
1,000 reviews.
That's crazy.
But there's so many Dream packs, though.
There's so many.
1,800 more kids bought this pack.
What the fuck?
Where are these children paying for my career?
I'm sorry.
Those poor kids.
Oh, my God.
Oh, my...
I can't believe 1,800...
At least...
That's, like, enough for the children that actually gave reviews.
Because, like, who the fuck reviews things, especially for Minecraft skin packs?
Is anything...
Oh, that's true.
What comes up?
Doki.
Doki Doki Club.
That could be a Doki Doki Literature Club right now.
Like...
Who...
Okay, okay.
There's...
There's these guys.
Wait, we're just, like, characters that aren't even in the game.
There is...
Let's go.
Oh, my God.
It could be Doki Doki Lit.
My Little Princess.
Animal Hoodies.
The Mafia.
Oh, my God.
Cute Bears!
Oh, my...
Oh, my God.
Wait.
Monsters.
Oh, my God.
That could be Sans Undertale.
So...
Okay, guys.
I know, like...
I talked about all of that stuff.
And we voted Gamer Girl.
Also, PowerPo.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Doki Skin Pack 1.
But, like...
Okay, guys.
I could be...
I could legitimately be Sans Undertale right now.
But, like, guys.
I could be Sans Undertale in Sanrio.
Also, let me look at cute bears real quick.
Okay, they're pretty cute.
But, like, I don't like...
The clothes are weird.
I don't know.
When they're not farming, it's just, like...
It's...
Trendy bears.
Oh, my God.
Oh, there you go.
Okay.
It's just the fact that they're not farming, so, like...
It's weird seeing them in any other clothes.
It's so weird seeing them in, like...
Actual...
Because then it gets into furry territory.
Farming bear is like...
Oh, they're just farmers.
But now, I'm like...
Oh, maybe it's, like, something more.
Like...
Alright, guys.
I'm sorry.
I'm gonna...
I'm gonna buy...
Guys, I'm sorry.
I just...
I really want to be Sans Undertale in...
Um...
Wait, there's better...
Wait, is this better Sans Undertale?
Does he look...
No, that...
He looks worse.
Which is the best Sans Undertale?
Oh, my God.
Feast streamers.
Am I in there?
Am I good enough?
I don't...
No.
I'm not even...
I'm not...
I'm not real, apparently.
VTuber teens?
Like, what does that even mean?
What does that even...
Anime...
I...
Okay.
What does VTuber teens mean?
VTubers are awesome.
Some are cute.
Some are funny.
And some are gamers.
And some just like to watch anime and chat.
But what's best about them is that they are all lovable.
Okay.
They're inspired by VTubers.
Okay, I can...
Oh.
Oh!
Okay.
That's just...
That's just Hololive.
Okay.
That's fine.
I guess I'm not inspiring enough.
I'm not...
It's alright, guys.
I'm just not that inspiring, I guess.
Why are they so...
It's like Hololive for kids.
Guys, it's Hololive for kids.
Alright.
I guess I wanna be Sans Undertale.
This is what I'm paying for.
I'm sorry for...
I know, like, you all wanted me to be Gamer Girl.
But then I realized...
I could pay to be Sans Undertale.
I can...
I could...
I could pay for that.
Alright, guys.
I'm spending 400 and I just bought Sans Undertale.
Yes, please!
Alright.
This is it.
That is the money I have used.
Alright, how do I use this?
I bought him.
So, like, how do I become him?
Give me Sans Undertale.
I legit...
I just bought money.
Wait, where is it?
Choose new skin.
I bought him.
Did I not spend my money?
No, I do.
I have 1,400 left.
Oh, there we go.
Okay.
Equip the monster.
Okay, you have equipped monster skin.
Okay.
I did it.
Alright, you heard the bleep sound because I did it, guys.
Alright.
Am I him now?
Did I do it?
Oh my god, I did it.
I...
But it's not over yet, guys.
You guys wanna know why it's not over yet?
Because...
I gotta wear some clothes right now.
I got...
Because it's time to...
Wait, where's my character?
Where's Sans Undertale?
Oh my god.
Wait.
Where is he?
Okay, create character.
Select from...
Where did he go?
Wait.
I spent all that time.
I can't put clothes on him?
What's the point?
What?
Wait a minute.
I'm a little concerned here.
I spent all that money, but where can I put clothes on him?
Excuse me.
Why can't I put clothes on my Sans Undertale?
I...
Are you serious?
I can't put clothes on my Sans Undertale?
No!
I was gonna put...
I'm so sad.
I've never been so sad before.
I was so ready to...
I was so ready to give him clothes.
I...
Oh my god.
I was like, oh my god.
I cannot wait.
I cannot wait...
To put clothes on my Sans Undertale.
Because down here...
Down here...
I can buy Sanrio clothes.
And I was so excited.
Because I was like, oh my god.
I cannot wait.
I...
I cannot...
I can't believe it.
We spent...
20 minutes looking at skins.
And I can't even put my Cinnamoroll...
I'm still gonna buy it.
I'm still...
I don't care.
I want my Cinnamoroll ears.
And then I'll buy...
Oh my god.
I could be...
Wait, can I wear...
This and...
This over it?
Can I wear the hood...
The clothes over it?
But like, I could...
I could...
Oh my god.
I could have been saying...
I'm only one IP at a time.
I'm still gonna...
Oh, this is free.
I'll buy this.
It's free.
Okay.
Alright.
It's okay.
I'm fine.
It's alright.
It's okay.
I know that...
I guess I'll make my own character, I guess.
No.
It's okay.
You don't need this.
You get to be Sans Undertale.
Who cares?
It's okay.
I get to be Sans Undertale.
It's alright.
It's okay.
You get to be something better.
Where the fuck is...
Okay, I cannot deal with the sensitivity for this.
Alright.
Seventeen.
Let's figure this out.
Video.
Full screen.
Alright, that's a lot better now.
Now that we're full screen, I feel a lot better.
Okay, let me fix...
Let me fix the screen real quick.
Okay.
Wait, how is this...
This is not full screen.
Wait, what?
Am I full screen now?
Okay, there we go.
There we go.
That should be perfect.
Alright.
Hide paper.
Hide HUD.
Oh yeah, we got...
Camera shake.
View bobbing.
Where's the...
Oh, Jesus Christ.
This...
Where's the FOV?
Oh my God.
This is so weird.
What FOV do we use?
I don't remember.
What's a good...
Sorry.
What's a good FOV...
For Bedrock?
No, it's because it's Bedrock, guys!
It's Bedrock!
Everything is reset, guys!
You think I actually want to play on...
Okay, 95.
Okay, I'll do 90.
Who plays Bedrock?
Well, um...
We are playing Hello Kitty, okay?
We're playing Hello Kitty.
That's why we're here.
Alright.
There we go.
Oh, that looks so weird, man.
It looks so weird on, like, 90.
Oh my God, it's like little cupcakes.
Oh my, finally.
I'm finally gonna leave.
I'm finally gonna leave this place.
Hello, Hello Kitty!
Okay, give me a sec.
I cannot...
90 is so weird.
90...
90 is so weird in Bedrock.
I can't lie.
Like, there's something off.
There's something off.
That's...
There's something weird right now.
I cannot explain it.
There's something weird in Bedrock 90.
Like, I don't know what...
How to explain it.
Okay, let's get this camera sensitivity.
Hello, Hello Kitty!
Hello, you're finally...
Sorry, I was too busy trying to become Sans.
You're finally here!
We've been expecting your arrival!
I'm Hello Kitty.
Welcome to our town.
Everyone is super excited to meet you.
It's all anyone's been talking about lately.
A real farmer!
That's super cool!
I'm sure we can all learn a lot from each other.
I thought you could use a few pointers to get you started with your new life on the farm.
Follow me!
Hello, Hello Kitty!
This is your crop field.
You can grow all kinds of delicious veggies and fruits here.
Some crops grow year-round and others can only be grown during certain seasons.
Spring is the season for strawberries, for example.
You'll need to buy some seeds, sow them in these planters, and make sure to water them every day.
This is basically Harvest Moon.
Harvest Moon for $10.
Before you know it, you have a fully grown plant.
Here's your barn.
It's where you keep your animals.
You don't inherently have animals, but when you do, they'll live in there.
All you have to do is put an order for an animal over at Kawaii Mart...
and I'll make sure to have your new friend delivered straight to your barn.
Convenient, isn't it?
I strive to give only the best service.
Come along!
We still have a lot to cover.
Alright.
I don't care about you, Hello Kitty.
Where can I meet my Oshii-san tomorrow?
Next, we're going up this way.
That's where we'll find the mines.
What?
What do you mean the mines?
In my Minecraft game?
Here it is, the entrance to the mine.
Make sure you visit the mine frequently to collect iron and stone.
You're going to need a lot for them if you plan to expand your farmhouse.
We yearn for the mine.
That's what they're doing in the Minecraft movie.
Steve was just a kid that really wanted to mine.
And you'll get there in no time.
Speaking of expanding your house, let's run back down to the farm.
I need to show you one last thing before we head to the town.
Alright.
Remember I mentioned upgrading your house?
That's what the board here is for.
This is the house upgrade board.
Sometime in the future, you'll be able to get your hands on blueprints.
Blueprints will help you plan for future home upgrades and expansions.
When you obtain or buy a blueprint, you'll be able to refer to this board...
and see what materials you'll need to upgrade your house and visualize your progress.
Upgrading your house will require wood, iron, and stone.
Interacting with the board will allow you to store any materials you get...
so you don't have to lug them around.
With that cleared up, let's take a little tour...
Oh my god, I can meet Simbaro!
Move out of the way, kitty!
Oh my god, she won't let me move.
We're almost at the town.
We're doing a tiny pit stop here.
Move out of the way, kitty!
See the stairs on your left?
That's where the lumber yard is.
Let's go take a peek, shall we?
Soon...
Is this... In this woodsy area...
I'm gonna push her down, just to get to Maushi.
You'll be able to collect wood from fallen logs.
Feel free to chop up any fallen logs you'll find.
You'll need an axe for that.
I can't chop the trees?
I have to chop...
Oh my god, Kurumi!
Let me out!
I need to talk to her!
We're here.
Welcome to town!
More accurately, welcome to the town square.
This is the hub for everyone and everything happening in the valley.
The town square is where we hold all our seasonal festivals...
and celebrations.
Do make sure you come by the town square when a festival is happening.
I think you'll enjoy them.
I'm sure it will make everyone else happy too.
We're actually having a spring celebration on day 8 of the season.
Don't forget!
Hopefully we'll see you there!
No!
Bring me back!
Kurumi!
Our town store.
It's as cute as its given name, which I came up with myself, by the way.
This is your go-to quick stop for everything and anything you'll ever need.
Now furniture...
Oh my god, Kurumi!
Oh my god, she's right in front of me!
She's right there!
We'll be known to sell new...
Please come by whenever you need to do some shopping.
We're open every day, even on the festival days.
The only days we don't open is when the weather is particularly bad.
But then, you shouldn't be going out anyway.
Better stay home and redecorate or something.
Anywho, that's the end of our tour.
I'll walk you back home.
Kurumi, no!
Don't walk me home!
Ah, Kurumi!
What is this?
We are home sweet home.
I know that was a lot of information in a small amount of time.
But you'll get the hang of everything on your own, I promise.
Before I leave, I have a few housewarming presents for you.
That's so fucked up, Hello Kitty.
How dare you, like, show me Kurumi and then took her away from me.
She ripped her out of my fucking hands.
A brand new watering can, a hoe, pickaxe, and axe.
This will help you get started.
And to make extra sure that I don't have you in a state of confusion, I prepared this neat little tablet with any and all information you need about the town and life on the farm.
I gotta run back to Kawaii Mark now.
Is this what we dragoons sound like when we see TokiCats?
Thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you.
I'll be seeing you around.
Bye bye!
Oh my god, it's like pink, too.
What the fuck?
Okay.
What is this?
Is this a tablet?
Okay, so like, I can actually farm?
How do I...
Is this already...
Okay.
Alright.
Okay, let me put some lettuce down.
And then...
Boop, boop, boop, boop.
Alright, I did it.
Can I make Koro-mi now?
Don't take me away from Koro-mi.
Don't take her away from me!
Oh!
I have level zero friendship weather.
Today is sunny.
I can't believe it.
They took her away from me.
What do I do?
Okay.
So I can chop wood.
And then I have to...
Oh wait, I should refill this.
How do I refill this?
Okay, no, that's me watering it.
Hello kitty, you did not teach me this game.
Like, I...
She didn't even teach me how to fucking refill my watering can.
Like, I can't even...
Can I cut these trees?
I can't even cut these trees!
They're owned by Sanrio!
Property owned by Sanrio.
Trees cannot be cut.
I can't believe it.
They locked the trees.
I can only cut trees that have fallen on the ground.
Who lives over there?
Wait, is that the town?
Oh my god, that's where Hello Kitty lives.
Sanrio owns them.
Trees cannot be cut.
I like how you can see Sans just running on the top left.
If you have any questions, I'll compile the information myself with the help of ChocoCat.
Wait, who lives up here?
Knock knock, I'm here to break in.
Oh my god, I'm in!
Okay, wait.
Does it have F5 here?
Mia Maoshi.
Get over here.
Sans Undertale and his Oshi.
Don't leave!
Where are you going?
Saburo, where did he go?
Where did he go?
That's right.
Mia Maoshi right here.
I broke into my Oshi's home.
But that's okay.
That's not okay.
Oh my god!
Do you love your Oshi enough to not break into your Oshi's house?
But like, it's different.
Oh my god!
Calm down!
Stay away from him!
What do you mean I'm as big as a fan?!
Fan!
You can't say that!
He loves me!
He is really...
Oh my god, that's so cute!
There's a little Cinnamoroll!
There's a little Cinnamoroll plushie!
Oh my god!
Do you think he'll notice if I take something from his house?
Aw, he might not.
Oh my god, he's calling the police!
Going up to Cinnamoroll and asks, I love you.
Oh my god, he has merch of himself!
He's just like me!
His entire home is designed out!
His entire home is just merchandise of himself!
That's gonna be me if I ever get a fucking Doki Bridge couch.
You know damn well I'm gonna put that on my Cinnamoroll.
Oh my god, your house is beautiful, Cinnamoroll!
Just don't leave this corner.
Your house is so beautiful!
Don't be scared!
Do not be afraid!
I'm your number one fan!
Do not be afraid, Cinnamoroll!
Alright.
Alright, I gotta meet my Oshie.
Don't do it!
I gotta meet my Oshie!
Oh my god, his house is so cute!
There's like bullets!
Do not be afraid!
Alright, let's see if I can find Kuromi's house.
I feel like that's definitely not.
Oh, that has to be like the twins, the star twins.
Oh my god!
Look at this fucking hunk of a man!
You should come over sometime.
I have a really cool bowtie collection.
I'm sure you would appreciate.
Oh, hi there, Cinnamoroll!
Clouds make for the best nap spots.
Oh my god, look!
He followed me.
Look at this absolute unit there.
Can't wait for the next pumpkin carving!
Make sure to try your hardest!
I'm a fun but picky judge!
He's not afraid!
See, he came to me!
Guys, he came to me!
Okay, guys?
Alright?
He is my friend now.
Okay, is that... which one could be Karomi's house?
I feel like Karomi's house would be black though.
But like... Oh, there's my melody.
Fuck off.
I don't... Oh, wait, hey!
There's Batsmots...
Batsimaru.
I've been thinking.
You're pretty cool, right?
But you know what would make you look even cooler?
Join the exclusive Rad Riders Scooter Club!
It's only the coolest club in town.
People will ooh and ah when they see you drive by.
Wow, I wish I was part of the Rad Riders Scooter Club.
It's so exclusive.
It only has one member at the moment.
Me, a president and founder, Batsimaru.
And by presidential degree, I selected you to be my number two pretty sweet offer.
To make you an official member, we gotta get you your own... Oh my god, I want my own scooter!
I just got a brand new one recently, so I can give you my old scoop.
See that scooter by my garage?
It's all yours.
Can y'all believe it?
It's a lucky day.
It's not in the best shape though.
I may have been a bit rough on it over the years, but it's nothing a good scrub and fresh layer of paint can fix.
I guess there's also a small detail of it needing some new wheels.
But hey, if you can bring me some paint and a new set of rollers, I can fix it up.
Aw, I got you.
Guys, we need that scooter.
Okay, Batsu... Oh, this has to be Koromi's house!
It's goth as fuck!
That has to be her house.
Knock knock.
Don't worry about the axe in my head.
Oh my god!
She has a fucking...
Wait, what the fuck?
Why did she...
Bro, she's rich as fuck.
Netherite armor, right?
Why does she have Netherite armor?
Oh, I like how like the music came down the entire Netherite.
Oh, she's a gamer.
She's a gamer gamer.
She actually has Netherite armor.
Hello, Koromi.
Oh my god, Tsunomoro doesn't even have a goddamn kitchen!
He lives in the slums!
See you again.
Oh, I'll be here definitely for sure.
Okay, this is Oshi number two.
My Tsunomoro is my Kamiyoshi.
But like...
I don't like that perspective.
But...
No, Koromi is way too pure for that.
Koromi... Oh, it looks like I'm peeking in.
Like I'm a little peeker.
Peeping Tom.
And I'm looking and I see Koromi and Sans under there.
Do not be afraid.
This is me and my Oshi.
Oshi number two.
Not my Kamiyoshi, but me and my Oshi right here.
Look at that.
Alright.
No, Koromi, please.
Please don't run away, Koromi, please.
Please don't run away.
Don't be...
Don't run away.
Don't run away, Koromi.
I'm just trying to take a photo.
Oshi number two.
Okay, there you go.
She just wants to feel tall, guys.
That's really it.
She wants to feel tall.
Please, Koromi, don't run.
Don't run.
There you go.
Oh my god, guys.
Did you guys take a photo of me and my Oshi?
Oh, why are you hiding?
Koromi, why are you hiding?
Why?
Oh my god.
I get to be in my Oshi's house.
I got invited.
She welcomed me in her home, guys.
Oh, her house is so cute, though.
Welcome to the tomato farm.
Welcome, welcome.
She welcomed me to her home.
Oh my god, there's like a playground, too.
That's so cute.
There's like hopscotch.
Hello, Tsunamoro.
Hello.
You want me to put you on the swing?
Come on.
Go on the swing.
That's right.
Wait, I can...
I mean, I could...
You were not invited.
I feel a little weird being in a playground.
Let me leave.
I don't want to...
Oh, there's Koromi!
I feel a little weird trying to kidnap Tsunamoro in the playground.
I'm...
I'm singing some tunes.
Who is here?
Oh, is this Helikitty's sister?
Oh, this is my melody?
Fucking hate you.
You'll never be like your sister.
You'll never be like her.
Koromi!
I'm like that like the crazy the crazy fan outside her window.
Koromi is better than you in every way.
You'll never be like her.
Get out.
Leave this town, Melody.
She's better than you.
I'm the auntie.
That's right.
Koromi is better than you in every way.
I like Melody.
Sometimes we get heatwaves during the summer season.
It's best to stay indoors and not risk getting heatstroke.
So be mindful.
That's right!
Move out of this town!
You're not welcome here.
An auntie, a hater, and I'm gonna throw eggs at her ass.
Who lives here?
Hello?
What the fuck?
Who lives here?
Oh, is that Batsumaru?
Oh my god, he's a gamer!
Wow, look at his PC!
Oh my god, he has a gamer chair too!
Wait!
He actually has a gamer chair!
Oh my god!
He's a goddamn gamer!
Yeah!
He's got the whole setup and everything.
Wait, I can like sit on his table.
Oh my god!
He's a fucking gamer!
Look at him.
No wonder he likes me so much.
He has the Marvel Rivals logo on his chair.
Wait, here.
He is like the only one with a PC too.
I'm gonna steal his setup.
Oh no, it's night time.
Wait, I'm not done!
I'm not done!
Going into people's houses!
Who lives here?
Knock knock!
Anyone notice that the relationship between Kuromi and Melody are similar to Spongebob and Squidward?
Yeah, I'm thinking for the super chat.
Oh my god, is this ChocoCat's house?
Your house is so...
Your house is so generic.
Oh my god!
Fucking nerd!
He's a goddamn nerd!
He has a calc... He has a TI-87 calculator here and everything.
There's like a science kid here.
He has a toaster.
Wait, where is he?
Oh, you try to hide.
That's right.
Who are you hiding from, huh?
Who are you hiding from?
That's right.
No!
Heya!
Let this cat go!
Let the cat go!
Doki!
Let him go!
That's right.
Why are you hiding?
Maybe a home intruder?
It's like, oh my god, he won't know.
Please!
Please help!
No one will save you.
I'm in your home now.
Dude, don't bully.
Get back to your corner, ChocoCat.
Go back to your...
Go back to... Oh, you're trying to run?
Oh, go back.
Go to this other corner.
That's right, ChocoCat.
Leave the cat alone.
It's him.
I'm so sorry.
If they didn't want me to invade their homes, they wouldn't have let me in in the first place.
He's just a chill cat.
Alright, who lives... Oh wait, that's the market.
Is it open right now?
Hello, hello, kit...
Oh, that's so cute!
They use, like, the levers and the light...
I like to buy stuff.
Oh!
Wait, that's so cute!
I can buy bees!
And milk!
2005.
How much money do I have?
I don't even know how much money I have.
It doesn't even tell me.
Hello Kitty, how much money do I have right now?
How much money do I have, Hello Kitty?
Wait, can I buy bees right now?
Oh, technically I can.
Okay.
I'll buy...
Wait, but what's this?
Oh, I have zero?
Oh, I don't have enough gems?
Okay.
Alright, I thought I had more.
Oh no, I'm slow.
I'm getting tired.
I'm getting so tired.
I can buy a chair.
Oh, these are like furniture.
Wait, what's this?
Did I buy it?
I just... I didn't know what it is.
Wait, did I buy it?
Did I...
Did I accidentally bought this?
No!
I'm passed out!
I did that!
Alright, now I have some balls.
I'm so sad.
I didn't want to buy these stupid balls.
I shoplifted and I passed out.
I'm so sad.
I wanted to save my money for bees.
I wanted bees!
Oh shit, I have a crafting table.
I don't... Wait, I don't have a crafting table.
Alright.
I'm so sad.
Imazayer, thank you for the superchat.
Thank you, thank you!
I'm happy that your team won.
Thank you for your first superchat!
Thank you, thank you!
Thank you!
I'm really happy my team won, too.
I also got invited... Oh, we have... I got invited to this guy's Toast Marble Rivals tournament, too.
I won't say the date because I don't think they announced it yet.
But yeah, I'm super looking forward.
I can actually play in a tournament.
I got the invitation today.
Alright, back to like...
Back to breaking... Not... Getting invited to like my Oshie's houses.
I'm going back in.
I'm not done.
I'm not done, guys.
I know this is a... Oh, I don't care about...
Oh, actually, I want to see what HowlKitty's home looks like.
It's raining and I'm gonna be like, knock knock.
Let me in.
Why is her house so much bigger than everybody else?
What is this?
What is this privilege?
Why does HowlKitty get to have a bigger house than all the other Sanrio characters, huh?
That's so messed up.
Why does she... She gets the best view and everything.
Why does she have all the privilege?
She's the main character.
No, she's not.
Cinnamoroll is the main character.
Oh, this is the absolute... The absolute chunky penguin boy.
Oh, that's so sad.
All he has is a fucking radio for entertainment.
That's so sad.
Hello, this game seems fun.
I wonder if we can allow it with the rest of the games.
Right, man.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I think the cool thing about Bedrock is the customization is really nice.
I like how his only form of entertainment is like a god damn radio.
He's old.
He's so... He's old.
Papa Puddin!
Oh my god, I'm gonna...
Oh my god!
Oh, she's number three!
Why are you running?
They're like, oh no, she's zombie.
Oh no.
What do I do?
What now?
I ran... Oh, you have to help.
Look, see, I'm a friend.
Not parasocial or anything.
He called me friend first.
Guys, he called me friend first.
I did something, mistakes were made.
They grabbed him.
They were there and then they weren't.
I want to hold a delicious pudding party and invite everyone to have a taste of my homemade pudding.
It's a special recipe.
My mom taught me how to make.
It's truly amazing.
The jiggle, the texture, the flavor.
Oh no!
Everyone seems so excited.
They expected our friends to come by soon.
So I got working and made the jiggliest, softest pudding.
But one thing led to another.
I wanted to make sure that taste was perfect.
I had a little taste and then a little lick.
I was delicious and I blinked.
I don't know what happened, but it's all gone.
Oh no.
What am I going to do?
Wait, of course, you have a farm.
Oh, friend.
Friend.
Guys, friend.
Remember.
You have to help me.
Could you bring me five bottles of milk?
Fresh milk is the key to whipping up my special pudding with another...
So I could make another batch in no time.
Leave it to me.
Guys, guys, he said I'm his friend.
Guys, he said friend.
He said...
Oh my God, his chairs are pudding themed!
I'm so cute!
Oh my God!
His entire decor is just pudding because he's Pom Pom Pudding.
He's like the chef.
Does he...
He has a bottle!
I see it!
Toki, why are you bending down?
Guys, guys, I just want to see that bottle.
Pom Pom Pudding's like, excuse me, um...
Why are you looking?
He has the bottle!
See?
Look at that, it's right there, Toki.
It's what he's known for!
Like Pom Pom Pudding has a little, like, extra butt.
Guys, it's actually what he's known for.
Toki, stop.
He's scared of you.
No!
He said friend!
He said friend, guys.
He said friend first.
Oh, and this is Kiropi's house.
It's canonical!
Yes!
Oh, you try to hide.
Ooh, a visitor.
You try to hide there.
You think I didn't see you?
Oh my God, that's so cute.
The little bow ties and everything.
Oh, he's like...
He likes to do karaoke.
Oh yeah, he likes to sing because he's a frontman.
And everything.
Oh, his house is pretty cute.
I also would say...
I don't have my axe out!
Now I do.
And this is...
Oh, I forgot his name.
I don't like this guy.
I don't like him.
It's a little weird.
Hang...
Hang Yodon?
Oh my goodness, visitor.
That's not to say this isn't a good surprise.
It's a wonderful surprise.
It's great.
Amazing.
Welcome to my humble little home by the water.
Oh my goodness, visitor.
What do I do now?
Tea?
Cake?
I don't have any of that.
Get a grip, Hang Yodon.
You're a host, yes.
Farmer friend.
It's only right that as your first time visiting, I give you the most amazing guest experience you have ever experienced.
And all of your experiences.
You'll have so much fun, you won't be able to help telling everyone about it.
It's so fun going to Hang Yodon's place.
There's no place like it.
What a host!
What a guy!
Anyway, let's play a little game.
I call it, dive deep to the bottom of the lake and retrieve the special limited edition Hang Yodon's action figure.
Yep, that lake there.
It will be fun.
Oh, I can't wait to see the glimmer in your eyes with all the fun you'll have.
Well, don't let me keep you off.
I'll wait here.
Okay, want me to dive into that lake?
Wait, what's in this lake?
Oh my God, how do I see anything?
I'm gonna kill you.
I'm gonna kill all the fishes in this lake.
Wait, where is he?
Okay, I need to go back up.
I need to find a special item in this lake.
He wants me to drown.
He's like, Hang Yodon!
You're our only hope for Sanrio Village!
Get rid of this monster!
And then he's like, don't worry.
Citizens, I shall send her on to a quest and then she'll drown.
And I shall be a hero.
That's been here, right?
There's a cave here.
Oh, there it is.
Nice, I got it.
Little do they know, I'm gonna finish this quest with understood.
I got a plan.
Alright.
Hello, I found it.
Oh, you thought you got a plan?
But little does he know.
Little does he know.
I found a figure.
That's right.
He didn't expect me to complete the mission.
You returned!
How?
So how was it?
You don't have to be shy.
It was the most fun you've had in a while, right?
Your clothes seem a little soggy, but that should take care of itself, right?
Haha!
I think I once heard something about wet socks.
What was it again?
I wouldn't know.
I don't wear them, you see.
Oh my god, bare feet.
Anyway, I, of course, have a prize for job well done.
Feast your eyes on this!
Limited edition, super rare, trendy, and chic, Hangodon's fishing rod!
Oh my god, I got a fishing rod!
Ooh, ah!
Try it out!
Oh my god, I got a fishing rod now.
Okay, how do I fish?
Is it the same?
Wait, I can't fish.
Oh, there we go.
Alright, fishies.
Come on.
What did I get?
Wait, what?
Guys, I don't know if I know how to fish.
Do I right-click or left-click?
Hahaha!
Guys...
Wait, I don't understand!
Is it not right-click?
Or is it left-click?
Oh guys, I don't think I know how to fish.
I don't...
Hahaha!
Guys, I don't think I actually know how to fish, guys.
Oh, there we go, I got it!
Oh, I got a tin can.
Wait, I figured it out.
I learned how to fish, guys.
Oh my god!
Why the fuck?
Where are my actual fish?
Why did I get a plushie?
What?
What is that?
I don't do fish in this fucking lake!
I'm gonna die!
I'm running out of cupcakes!
I'm actually gonna...
Oh my god, it's just garbage.
Who is polluting this lake?
Oh, Sanrio Town.
Somebody is actually polluting this lake right now.
I unlocked the recipe though.
What do I unlock?
It's just garbage!
It's literally just garbage.
All I've been fishing is just garbage.
It's actually crazy.
There's only garbage in this town.
I'm gonna steal Kuro-pi.
There has to be...
Wait, what if there's fish in Kuro-pi's pond?
Is that possible?
Can I steal Kuro-pi's fish in his neighborhood?
No, there's no fish in Kuro-pi's pond.
It's a dead pond.
Alright, alright.
You thought I wouldn't invade your house?
Too late, I'm coming in.
I'm just cleaning up the pollution.
Oh, there's like a pearl.
Oh, there's like a little octopus plushie.
That's so cute.
I don't know.
Oh, it's like...
He uses like...
Oh, and there's fishes up top!
I'm gonna keep breaking.
It's a dead pond in Kuro-pi land.
I was gonna steal his...
I was gonna steal his fish.
Because I couldn't find anything else.
Okay, I'm starving.
Like, how do I eat in this town?
Anyway, like...
I'm...
I can't run anymore.
I can't run.
I'm so hungry.
I looked at...
I looked at this house.
I looked at Penguin house.
I looked at Batsumaru house.
ChocoCat.
Wait, who lives here?
I haven't looked at this house yet.
Wait, is this ChocoCat's?
No, that was ChocoCat.
Who lives here?
Why is it so dark?
Oh, it's Pochacco!
Why is your house so dark, Pochacco?
Oh, look.
Oh, there's the sport balls.
And then he's like a sporty guy.
Why don't you have food, Pochacco?
I am a guest in your home.
Where's my food?
Why do you have lights out, Pochacco?
All I've been doing is just invading people's homes.
Instead of fucking farming.
I've not been, like, doing anything else but, like, just breaking into people's houses.
Okay, I need to sell all this junk that I have so I can buy food at the market.
Hello Kitty must have food.
Hello Kitty must have food for me.
There's no way.
Sell.
Wait, can I not sell...
...this junk?
What the fuck do I do with...
Wait, I can't sell this?
What?
Oh, there we go!
Okay.
I mean, I'll take the Batsumaru.
Alright, I have 51 hearts now.
But, like, how many hearts do I have in total?
It doesn't even tell me how many hats I have.
It's cause I bought that stupid ball.
I bought that stupid fucking ball.
I'm so sad.
I actually could've had enough.
I could've had enough for bees.
I bought that stupid ball.
I bought that stupid ball!
So I don't have fucking bees!
It's okay, I don't need bees.
I don't need bees.
Those stupid little Choco Balls.
I don't need them.
Okay, I think I didn't see...
I didn't visit...
Twin Stars.
My little Twin Stars.
Hello, I'm gonna go into your house, guys.
Your house is next.
I'm coming over.
But the balls are so far.
They're like...
They're like in my home.
And I'm hungry.
I'm so hungry.
Hi, things on the 5.
I'm so very hungry.
Oh my god, you still have to live in a bunk bed?
I'm so sorry.
Wait, but who's on the other side?
Wait, what?
Why is there a locked door on the other side?
What secrets do you have, Lala?
What?
What secrets do you have over there?
Oh my god, Lala.
What do you have over there?
Why can't we go to the other house, Lala?
That's creepy.
That's a little creepy.
Okay, we gotta head home.
Oh no, I'm slowed.
I'm hungry and I'm gonna die.
I don't understand.
How do I get food?
Animal husbandry.
Resource gathering.
Friendship.
Help and you will raise your friendship levels.
Okay, but like...
How do I get food?
Resource gathering.
Mining and logging.
Visit the lumber yard.
Oh, I don't know where any of these is.
No!
I'm heading back as fast as I can!
Which is not very fast.
I passed out.
It's fine.
It's alright.
There has to be food in my house, right?
Oh my god, I have food!
Oh, the taiyaki is so cute!
Alright, I'm gonna eat some onigiri.
And then refill it up.
Oh, that is so cute though!
I'm gonna get my boba tea.
Okay, there we go.
A boba!
It's so silly seeing sans holding up.
Oh my god, look at that.
I'm so kawaii.
Just drinking my boba tea as sans.
Just another day for sans undertale.
Alright, time to...
Oh wait, can I farm them now?
No, they still need to be watered.
Alright, let's see.
Okay, it's time to gather some resources.
Let's actually get some work done, guys.
Let's actually do the Minecraft in this Minecraft game.
Oh wait, or go to the mines.
My body yearns for the mines.
Let's go.
Classic sans, drinking boba.
Is this all I have to do?
Can I not- oh wait, whoops.
Wait, can I not mine amethyst?
How the fuck do I play- How the fuck do I mine in this Minecraft game?
Oh, this is how you mine.
When they start sparkling.
Okay.
Let's grab this.
Oh, it's like stardew.
What did I get?
This is iron.
Okay, what do I do with iron though?
I should read the tutorial.
There's glowing rocks.
Yeah, I'm getting the rocks right now.
You have to like...
mash it.
For it.
Oh, this is a big boy.
A big boy, a big stone.
It's mining with extra steps.
Yeah.
Like, I'm like, there's gold over here.
Give me the gold.
Like, I don't understand.
It's a full gold block.
Why can't I have it?
It's just sitting there.
Like, I don't...
Give me the gold.
The goblin demands the gold.
It's just taunting me.
It's got them- Look, they have the goddamn gold all the way there.
And I can't do anything about it.
It's just sitting there taunting me, being like, you could have this gold, but you can't.
And they're just taunting me now.
Showing me the gold.
But I can't do anything about it.
Give me the gold.
The goblin demands the gold.
This is Hello Kitty.
I'm sorry.
Only Hello Kitty can have this gold.
What is it?
Are these stairs?
Oh, is this like mini parkour?
For the children?
Like, look at this.
Look at this.
I can't believe it.
It's just there.
It's just sitting there.
Why is it just sitting there?
Kids at first.
Parkour.
All of these.
It's just sitting there taunting me.
Being like, you can't have this.
It's mocking me.
Parkour civilization.
You're like, Hello Kitty's like, that's right.
That's right.
You can't have this.
This is owned by Hello Kitty.
Alright, I have so much rocks.
I don't know what to do with all this rock.
But I have a lot.
I guess this is for upgrades, right?
Alright, I'm ready to head out.
Will you jump for the boba tea You're the only Geary.
Well, I got my resources here.
You can put your...
Your resources at a billboard.
Okay, let's see.
Let me actually read the tutorial.
Tutorial.
Resource gathering.
Binding.
Okay, that's not what I wanted.
Where do I put my stuff?
I don't understand.
Oh, house upgrades.
There you go.
Upgrade board.
Uh, appear on the board.
You can find the upgrade board outside your house.
Oh, okay.
Outside my house.
Is it that?
That has to be it.
That's my board right there.
Hello?
Take my stone.
That's...
Take...
Take it!
That's the board!
Your need to complete will also appear on the board.
Just interact with the materials on the board to deposit them.
Take it.
Take the stone!
Oh my god.
Oh my god, why won't it take my stone?
Oh!
Is it this?
What the fuck is this?
Oh, I need a blueprint?
Okay, clearly I didn't read all my rules then.
Alright, tutorial.
House upgrade.
Blueprints.
These will allow you to...
Oh, okay.
That makes more sense now.
Okay, I doesn't understand.
Doki doesn't understand children games.
Woah, this is creepy.
What's over here?
Oh, it's like a little shortcut!
I see you.
I built this.
Doki.
I see you, Sanrio Town.
I built this.
Just so I can get here faster.
A secret tunnel into their homes.
She stalks from the shadows.
I wonder if I can buy blueprints at Hello Kitty's place.
Alright, Hello Kitty.
I need to know, do you have blueprints for me?
Someone stop this.
Stop me.
What do you mean it's not creepy?
How is it creepy?
I just love them so much.
Basic white paint.
Where's house upgrades?
Is it this?
I still can't afford it.
I'm not rich enough.
Alright, let's go back then.
No gems.
I did not corner any residents in their homes.
Stop spreading these fake news and fake propaganda, guys.
I did not corner anybody.
They invited me to their homes and I just happened to be in the corner, guys.
Stop spreading this fake propaganda and like slandering me or you're gonna be talking to my lawyer.
They were already in the corner.
How would I corner anybody if they were already in the corner, guys?
They were already there.
I just happened to walk over there.
Okay, and then I got the logs.
Log time.
Streamer reflects the viewer.
Alright, let me deforest this forest real quick.
This miniature forest.
I'm so sad I can't cut the big trees.
It's just there standing there.
It's literally just there standing there waiting for me to cut.
Waiting for me to be like chop chop.
How do I find wheels?
I need wheels and I'm like how?
I guess like the market would have wheels?
Okay.
I don't understand.
It's better if I can just chop the fresher trees.
Fresh trees equals better wood.
Why do I have to chop dead trees?
Give me the fresh trees.
I yearn for the fresh trees.
Let me cut the fresh trees.
I wanna explore this.
Oh wait, that's back home.
Okay, I'm gonna eat my onigiri real quick.
So I just gotta eat the onigiri and then drink some boba tea.
Alright, I could fish a little bit.
Maybe I can grab some stuff I can sell at the market.
I wanna have enough so I can have a cow!
Where are the fishies?
Did I over...
Did I overfish already?
Where are the fishies?
Where are my fishies?
Oh no.
Did I...
Did I already fished all the fishies in this lake?
Oh no, there it is.
Oh my god, get money.
Wait, how much money is that?
Surprise token?
How the fuck do I use a surprise token?
Oh my god, it keeps giving me a tin can.
I've never had a fish yet.
I've never fished an actual fish.
Oh wait, I got...
I got an empty bottle!
For the milk!
For the milk for the cows!
Okay, that's alright.
Come on.
Give me my fishies.
One fish, that's all I want.
Just one fish.
Oh my god, this lake is so polluted.
There is...
There is something wrong with this town.
Why is it all just...
Why is it all just fucking trash?
Hello Kitty is hiding something in Sanrio Town.
Hello Kitty is hiding something.
Why every time my fish is just trash?
It's not the perfect town they all want you to think it is.
The lake is only a waste of...
This pose.
She's hiding something and I'm gonna...
I'm gonna discover it.
Alright, let's see.
Oh shit, hey.
Why are you freaking out again?
Oh, what do I do?
Oh, you have to help me.
Mistakes were made.
They were there and then they weren't.
Oh wait, it's the same mission.
It's the same one.
Okay, uh...
What is this token for?
Is it for this?
Oh!
It's a gachapon.
What did I get?
I got a kitchen!
I can finally wash my hands!
Alright, I need to sell my junk real quick.
Let me sell my junk.
Alright, Hello Kitty, I got some junk for you.
Uh...
Okay, I got the tin can.
And I'll just...
There you go.
Nice, one dollar.
Nice.
Uh...
What else can I sell?
I need like blueprints, but I don't know how to get blueprints.
They never told me how to get blueprints!
They're just like, welcome to this new world.
Be free.
I'm like, what?
How the fuck am I supposed to figure out what blueprints?
Where do I upgrade?
Oh my god.
Please sell this.
I'm just gonna... I might as well sell my resources cause like, I don't know what else to do with it.
They're just like, welcome to this world.
Now just do, I don't know, just survive.
Like, I'm like, what do I do with all my...
I'm just gonna sell this.
I don't need any of this yet.
I want my bees.
Take it.
Okay.
And then...
Pew!
Get it in.
Get this in.
Alright.
Do I have everything?
Oh, I can sell iron.
How much does iron give me?
That's fine.
Oh my god, can I afford bees now?
Can I afford bees?
Yay!
Bees.
Yeah!
Oh my god, guys.
I got bees.
With no bees in it though.
I don't have bees.
I'm gonna toil in the mine so I can buy bees for my bees.
I got a bee hive!
Let's go!
I can finally go home!
Bees but no bees.
It's okay.
We're getting there!
The bees without the bee.
Wait, how do I...
Where's my cave that I dug?
I dug a cave right here somewhere.
Oh, I forgot.
Where's my transportation cave?
Oh, it's right here.
There you go.
My little shortcut that I dug.
I can see you, Sanrio Town.
I'm sorry.
I should stop.
Where do I put this?
Wait, it says bee upgrade.
Do I even have a...
Wait a minute.
How do I...
Do I even have...
Do I even have a bee house?
Wait.
I bought this for no reason.
Where's my bee house?
How do I...
How does one use the bees?
I don't...
How do I use the bees?
Did you get scammed?
They're...
Live, farm, love.
But like, how do I use this?
Wait a minute.
The bee field is opposite to my house?
Oh my God, where the fuck is that bee hide?
What was the point?
Oh no, I'm getting tired.
Wait.
I'm trying to...
Guys, please.
I'm trying to figure out...
Oh, it's right here.
Oh my God, I did it.
It's right here.
Okay, there you go.
I got this.
And then tomorrow, I live in the mines so I can buy bees.
Oh my God, for the first time, I'm not gonna pass out.
Where's my bed?
Sleep.
For the first time in my Hello Kitty adventure, I actually will not pass out.
Oh my God, I did it.
Day four.
Apparently, in day eight is where, like, things get crazy.
Oh shit, okay, let me get rid of the pachaco.
If I... I can farm less if I can sell my pachaco balls.
I can't... I can't believe I accidentally bought those balls.
I didn't know what they were.
I was like, what?
I didn't know you right-click it and then you literally bought it by... Oh wait, can I farm this?
Oh my God, I can farm lettuce now.
Oh my God, finally.
Finally.
Okay, and then, back to the mines I go.
Back to the mines I go.
Hello Kitty owns me.
She forces me to go into the mines.
Taunting me with her fucking gold.
Alright, back to the mines I go.
So I can buy bees.
The things I do for bees.
I yearn for the mines.
So I can have bees.
And then when I get the bees, I can have...
I'll be able to have cows!
Okay, cows are endgame.
We don't stop until I get the cows.
The bees, no.
For the bees.
I feel like... No, this is worse than being in debt to Tom Nook.
This is a lot worse.
At least Tom Nook doesn't force me to go into the mines and then show me the gold that I cannot touch.
That's... This is honestly much more worse.
I need the milk.
I just need the milk.
Please.
I yearn for the milk just like Homelander.
This economy fucking sucks.
Into the mines.
Oh, am I like running out?
There's like so little I should actually save up for the iron though.
Whoa.
But not like that though.
But not exactly like that.
It's so weird that you have parkour here.
Like it's like baby's first parkour.
Oh my god.
Is she gonna get top 500 in this game?
Please!
Let me have my bees and cows!
It's like a thousand dollars for a fucking cow too.
Like...
If...
Okay, if Hello Kitty is so nice, why don't she just give it to me for free?
She's already a billionaire.
Like, why does she want more money than me, huh?
Why does she want more money from me, huh?
If she's so rich.
Look, she owns Sanrio Town.
She literally owns the only market in this town.
Everything goes towards Hello Kitty.
None of the other residents have like... have any way of earning money.
Hello Kitty doesn't give handouts.
Oh fuck.
She's rich for a reason, Doki.
Yeah, but like I could be a tax write-off.
I don't understand!
I could be a good tax write-off for her.
You know, when people do charity stuff, it's to help for taxes.
Like, I could be that guy.
Explains how...
Her house is so much bigger than all the other residents, not gonna lie.
And she has a garden.
None of the other residents has a garden like her.
Using it as a tax write-off is wild.
You know, that's why a lot of people do charities.
Charity stuff for like the rich people.
Like, you can be like, oh, I have like my own like charity what is it called?
Like this charity foundation and stuff like that.
Or like, a lot of them just do it for tax write-offs.
I could be your tax write-off, Hello Kitty!
It could be me!
Okay, I'm just gonna go in here, have some fucking rocks.
Okay, I should be able to afford a bee, right?
Bye.
Can I get to buy some bees?
Oh my god, I can buy one queen bee!
Yes, alright.
Soon, I will be rich enough for a cow.
Alright guys, we're saving up for a cow.
What the fuck is that?
Is that a pig?
Why is a pig more expensive than a cow?
What am I gonna do with a pig?
Eat it?
Oh, I guess that is what I'm gonna do with a pig.
I see bees in mine's doughkeeper too.
I see them zoom for me and for you, and I think to myself, what is wrong with this world?
Upside down, thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you!
That's a chunky ass pig, yeah.
This bacon economy.
Oh, for the truffles?
There's truffles in this world?
It's okay guys, I got the queen bee.
I'm gonna save up the iron, so like I don't have to worry, cause I feel like iron's gonna be super important for upgrading.
Alright.
What?
Hello Kitty does not believe in welfare.
Hello Kitty uses scabs when workers are on strike.
Why do you think there's no- Why do you think she's working in the market herself?
She trusts no one.
She doesn't hire employees.
That's a waste of her money.
Alright, let's get some wood real quick too.
Since we're here.
I don't even think I like- How do I get back my HP?
Am I forever gonna- What happens when I die in Hello Kitty Town?
Do I die in- In real life?
Does Hello Kitty own me?
Can I even die in Hello Kitty World?
Alright, let me cut some trees.
Put the queen bee out in the- Put the queen bee in her bee keeping house and then like die.
I'm curious.
I'm actually- I'm actually curious what happens if I die in Hello Kitty World.
I'm gonna do it.
She has pushed me too far, guys.
She has pushed me too far.
It's time.
Time to test that theory.
Hello Kitty.
You have done too much!
Your reign in Hello Kitty Land ends here.
My death will cause a rebellion for the people of Sanrio.
You literally worked for two days.
Two days too many.
I can't believe I worked for two days and I still don't have my cows.
I will start the revolution.
Alright, queen bee.
Yay!
How do I get honey?
Okay, but now, how do I get the honey though?
Oh, gems.
Oh, I have to look in the tutorial to see the gems?
What the fuck kind of bullshit is that?
Alright.
Apiculture.
Okay.
You can paint your hive using- you can find many different colors.
Hives can be harvested every seven days in spring.
Once your hives have a queen in them, when you see honey dripping, it is time to collect it.
Honey, use it on the hive to calm down the bees.
Empty jar.
Oh, I have to grab a smoker?
And like, why can't I- Oh my god, what are you gonna do?
Sting me in a death fucking final.
Then I shall be free.
Okay, let me put my items away, guys.
Let me put my items away.
I didn't know I had to look at the goddamn tutorial?
To like, figure out how much money I have?
Oh, I forgot to put this away.
Alright, hold on.
Put these away.
Okay, it's time.
It's time.
I know the perfect place to make a statement.
I know a perfect place to make a statement to Hello Kitty and her reign of terror.
And her reign of terror.
To the mines I go.
Alright.
I will not be ignored or silenced.
I shall- Oh my god, okay, first off, let me like, figure out how to parkour again.
Let me- Oh my god.
I shall make a statement to the world of Hello Kitty land.
She cannot control us.
She cannot control us!
Oh, wait.
Whoops.
Alright, this is it.
This has to be the final jump.
I thought landing on the spike would end it faster, but apparently not.
For the beast!
Jokey fell from a high.
You died.
Oh, I just come back to life.
Okay, I need to get my stuff.
You cannot leave.
You're here forever.
Hello Kitty owns you now.
You must be like, how the fuck does she die in a Hello Kitty DLC?
I cannot.
I guess I go back.
There is no escape from Hello Kitty world.
There's my work equipment.
Back to work I go, I guess.
Back to the mines I go.
You're here forever.
Why'd you stop mining?
Jokey.
Hello Kitty requires more stone.
Why'd you stop mining?
No one lives in Hello Kitty land.
Hello Kitty monopolizes all.
Now I'm a Sanrio character.
Wasn't that a nice break?
Your watering can?
It's alright.
I have another watering can at home anyway.
Thank you my Hello Kitty overlords for my watering can.
Thank you.
Thank you for the water.
Oh, you lost your watering can?
Don't worry.
That's what we're here for.
So you can have more.
Okay.
I guess I can sell my wood.
Wait, actually.
Dying in Hello Kitty land.
Dying is so much more efficient.
If I die, I don't have to eat.
I can just respawn.
Wait, it's just so much more.
Why the fuck would I eat if I can just die?
That's crazy.
I just have to go to the mines every time I'm hungry.
It's just that easy.
Gamers never dies.
That's a wild thing.
What?
It's true.
I just have to like, if I'm ever hungry, I just go in the mines.
Maxing in Hello Kitty world.
All I'm saying is that there's no point in eating at this point.
Alright.
So, I have some rock for you, my queen.
And also some wood.
And some more wood.
And also, like, lettuce.
Oh my god!
Wait, lettuce is money?!
And also this.
Wait, how much is this?
Oh, that's $200.
Wait, oh my god.
Wait, why the fuck am I selling you stone?
Okay, let me buy some.
Let me buy some lettuce.
Lettuce.
What is this?
Fertilizer.
Lettuce seed.
Okay, lettuce.
Alright, maybe I should get some eggplants too for the memes.
And then, some corn.
Oh, I bought two lettuce.
Whoops.
Oh my god, more lettuce for everybody.
Wait, I have so much money, I can buy sheep, cow, pig, chicken.
Wait, I should buy chicken.
I might as well.
I'll buy chicken.
Okay, and then I can lock chicken!
Oh my god, I'm gonna buy... Okay, wait, wait, wait.
Okay, smoker, shears, empty jar, empty bottle, ammo.
I'm gonna buy...
I'm gonna... Wait, chicken locked?
Oh, I need more.
I need... Okay, how much money do I have?
Tutorial.
How much money do I have?
I have a thousand dollars left.
Oh, do I want...
Should I get sheep?
I might as well.
Fuck it, I'm gonna buy sheep too.
We're almost there at endgame anyway.
Okay, and then... Oh, I don't have shears.
It's alright, I don't need shears yet.
Alright.
I don't need smoker.
The bees... I just don't... I need five days to fucking make enough for it.
And that's enough rock.
I can farm more rock.
I have my sheep.
And my chicken.
And I can farm chicken eggs!
Chicken eggs must be like super expensive anyway, right?
It's time.
Where's the cave that I made?
My secret tunnel.
Goodbye.
Goodbye, Sanrio Land.
Alright.
Where's my...
Where's my chicken house?
Wait, where is it?
Where will my chickens be?
Let's see.
Okay, no.
Wait, where will my chickens be though?
It never told me where it is.
Where does my chicken live?
I'll be back tomorrow.
There we go.
I'm tired.
I'll look at the chicken tomorrow when I wake up.
Wait,
how is that creepy?
I'm just saying goodbye.
How is that creepy?
Oh, just cause I wanted to say goodbye to my friends.
I'm a creep.
Alright, are they in here?
Is this where my chicken lives?
Oh, there they are!
I got chicken!
Oh my god, my sheep's naked!
Wait, how do I...
How do I gather my resources?
Okay, it's time to...
Oh my god, wait, there's an eye of ender in my fucking...
Alright, it's time to read.
Okay.
Tutorial.
Wait, no, not that one.
Back to tutorial.
Animal husbandry.
Farm animals.
You'll need to feed your animals everyday.
Animal feed can be bought.
Use empty bottles to collect.
Use shears to collect wood.
Chickens produce...
Okay, so I just need to give them animal feed and then they'll be fine.
Okay, I need to go back to... Wait, how much gems do I have?
Tablet.
Gems.
162.
Okay, that should be enough.
See, it hasn't produced a honey yet.
There's no yellow.
Okay, then I'm gonna go get some rocks then.
Okay, here we go.
Okay, boop.
Boop.
Oh, I can farm this now.
Nice.
Alright, I should have enough.
I need to feed my fucking sheep and my...
There's no way to like make it make animal feed too.
So Hello Kitty just...
Goddamn capitalistic bitch.
This is why Cinnamoroll is my Kamiyoshi.
I can't even make my own animal feed.
I gotta buy from her.
I gotta... She owns everything.
She owns the entire town.
She owns...
She owns the people.
She owns everybody.
I can't even... I don't even have a scooter because I need to buy wheels from Hello Kitty.
I need to buy paint from Hello Kitty.
I need to buy wheels.
Where are the wheels, Hello Kitty?
Where can I obtain the wheels?
She owns me.
All I can do is just dig.
All I can do is just mine in this town.
That's my entire existence.
Just mine, doggy.
Just mine.
Our corporate overlord wants more rock.
I can't even upgrade my farm.
All I can do is just sell the rock back to her.
That's the difference of...
Alright.
It's fine.
And now I'm tired.
Now I'm hungry.
Is this what you want, Hello Kitty?
I'm hungry now.
I'm hungry.
I can't even...
The only food I have is in my chest.
What happens when I eat all my food in the chest?
Intentional servitude with Hello Kitty.
More mining, less complaining.
What do I do when I run out of food, Hello Kitty?
Do you want me to just jump off in the mines?
Alright.
I need to go back to my house to...
Eat, guys.
Guess I'll die.
Alright.
Let's see.
They don't even refill my food.
I think that's the most messed up part.
I eat and eat, but they don't even refill it.
Like...
Every day...
You have energy to complain.
You have energy to eat up my...
That's wild.
That's freaking wild.
Alright, back into my dungeon.
If I want real creepy, I can be like this, guys.
This is real creepy.
This is the real creep factor.
Wait.
Hello, Hello Kitty.
I'm back.
Hello.
Alright.
Let's see.
I gotta sell...
I gotta sell my...
Lettuce.
And...
And my rocks.
My five lettuce and rocks.
I guess I could buy more lettuce.
Lettuce is really fast to grow.
It'd be creepy if you weren't Sans Undertale.
I'm literally a skeleton.
How much more creepy can it get?
Alright.
So...
Um...
Take my rocks, my lettuce.
Yeah, I wanna keep the iron.
And...
Okay, that's 350.
And then that is...
Because one rock is like $1.
Okay, 414.
Alright.
I need animal feed.
Hello Kitty, because you own me anyway.
There you go.
There we go.
Two animal feed.
And then I don't need shears yet.
Because I feel like...
Let's just buy shears for now.
And then...
Let's just buy more lettuce.
Alright, there we go.
Oh, I bought pumpkin.
I bought pumpkin!
Okay.
I didn't mean to buy pumpkin seeds.
I can't even grow them.
I can't even grow my pumpkin.
I was like, what?
How did I select a pumpkin?
Grow me, can you make me happy?
Bitch, I don't even fucking care anymore.
I asked you to make me happy and you talk about Hello Kitty to my face?
How could you?
You know that's my trigger warning.
You know that's a trigger!
They're all working on their big kitty.
They're all working for her.
On their big kitty.
Oh, not tolerant.
I can't even grow pumpkin.
What do you want from me?
I can't even grow it.
Okay, this, this.
Oh shit.
Fuck, I wasted the pumpkin.
And then I wasted the pumpkin seed.
It's not gonna grow anyway.
I wasted it.
I wasted the pumpkin seed.
My pumpkin's just gonna die.
I grew it just for it to die.
Alright, eat.
Eat.
Will it just grow?
I have to feed it by hand?
Are you serious?
Is that it?
It looks like a dog when he's naked.
It actually looks like a dog.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, this is gonna take forever.
Guys, I just want a cow.
That's all I want.
I just want to buy a cow and then look at him.
And then I'm free.
I don't even need to do anything else.
Just give me the cow.
That's all I want.
The big corporal man.
The big kitty.
Alright, if I sleep, then I go to the next day.
And then maybe I'll...
Today is spring 5.
We're almost there.
I yearn for the cow.
That's all I want.
Cow is my endgame.
Please.
All I want is a cow.
Oh my god.
When did I wear glasses?
Wait, wait.
Oh, no.
I accidentally wore it.
Oh my god, what happened?
How did I get my glasses on?
Sorry, I'm a little...
I'm hungover now from...
From big kitty.
Not the sad...
When I get the cow, it's over.
Okay.
Cow is drawn.
It doesn't even have anything.
Oh my god, the egg!
Wait, I saw it.
Oh my god, I got an egg.
Guys, I got an egg.
Oh my god.
Make sure I don't accidentally eat the egg.
Oh my god, my one egg.
I'm gonna sell you, my child.
I'm gonna put you in the market.
I'm gonna grow up.
No.
My dead pumpkin.
I'll just keep it there.
As like...
As like a reminder of what I did.
Not the egg goon.
I don't know what's gonna happen to you.
But I'm gonna sell you, my child.
Alright.
Where are the egg goons at?
Where are the egg goons?
Yeah, where are you guys?
Where are the egg goons in my chat?
Jarhods, I'm gonna fuck you.
Say goodbye, Jarhods.
You're gonna work for Big Kitty.
That's your new life.
Now you're about to be sold to Big Kitty.
You're gonna be working for Hello Kitty.
Till you die.
After I sell you.
That's right.
The horror is real.
Goodbye.
Alright, let's grab this.
I still don't know what to do with this.
Sold into the life of hardship at birth.
Welcome to the industrial revolution.
Now you...
Welcome.
Now you know what...
Honestly, that's basically the industrial revolution.
Back then, the poor would have so many kids.
So they can send the children to the factories.
And then when the child dies.
By being crushed by machinery.
They just pop another kid.
And be like, alright, off to work you go.
That's gonna be your...
Jarhod.
That's gonna be a woman.
Into the factory.
To make those Hello Kitty products.
Why do you think merch is so...
Why do you think merch is so popular?
In Sanrio.
It's off to the...
Factory you go, Jarhod.
You're gonna be out there making Hello Kitty pencils.
And plushies.
Is that great?
My child, I wonder how much money you'll get for me.
My child.
No, please.
Out of the womb.
And straight to the tomb.
Spare him of this fate.
Alright.
Off you go.
I wonder how much money you're gonna fetch me.
Little guy.
Please.
He's but a lad.
Best time to start.
Alright.
He'll learn faster at birth.
I'm heading over.
He's never known freedom.
That's the best part.
How much money?
You're only $50?!
Oh my god.
That's fine.
$50 is $50.
I'm okay with that.
That's alright.
Goodbye.
Off to the mines you go.
My $50 child.
That's okay.
Off to the mines you go.
My $50 child.
I am okay with that.
The egg yearns for the mines.
The shell sharpen it.
The shell grind it.
I had to purchase this one by one.
That's so fucked.
That's actually...
Your body gave me...
That allowed me to purchase half of...
Animal feed.
To produce more children.
Thank you for your service, child.
Your body lets me...
Produce more eggs.
Goodbye, jar hoods.
Goodbye.
This is gonna be a long cry.
Okay, I need to eat my natto.
Yeah, still net positive.
That's all that matters.
I'm still net positive.
I'm almost there to the cow, guys.
We're almost there.
I just wanna look at the cow.
That's all I want.
I just wanna see the cow.
I wanna say hello to him.
Be like, hello big boy.
I did this all for you.
I sold a child for you.
Do I have honey yet?
No, I don't.
It's like five days.
How is it not five days yet?
Alright, back to sleep I go.
Sleep I go.
I need more food.
I'll eat my fluffy pancakes.
I mean, maybe I'll sell the plushie.
I don't care much about the plushie or the algae.
I need more money anyway.
Oh, I forgot to feed my chicken!
Oh, fuck.
Okay.
I mean, it's one day.
It's one day.
It's fine.
Oh, tomorrow is the festival!
I sold my son for $50.
Oh shit, it's already done.
Nice.
That's good.
Oh, they grow so fast.
I should farm more lettuce.
It's alright.
I have food for them now.
No sun selling today.
Hello, I have food for you.
Alright, now they'll produce me...
They'll produce food.
They'll produce an egg tomorrow.
Don't get honey, it's a scam.
Oh yeah, I thought it reminded me.
I need to uninstall honey.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Jen, thank you for the super chat.
The end of the stream will be Doki challenging Hello Kitty for control over the town.
Oh my god.
First off, I need... Oh wait, I need the mines.
I got a mine.
It's 2,500 for a fucking cow.
Oh my god, I could've just bought a cow right away.
I didn't even need the chicken.
Alright, it's time.
Yeah, I have... I've always had the plug-in.
There's my dead pumpkin.
It's alright.
Well, I'm just keeping it there as a reminder of my mistake.
What it could've been.
Well, I didn't get scammed for the pumpkin.
I just, for some reason, accidentally clicked the pumpkin seed.
I don't know how.
I don't...
The worst part about this is that each rock is $1.
So I'm literally working below minimum wage at the mine.
For my corporate overlord, Hello Kitty.
I'm working like...
It's like...
It's $1.
It's only $1.
Oh my god.
It's not even $2.
It's $2.
It's poetry.
I'm working below minimum wage to make this work.
To make this work in Hello Kitty land.
Alright.
You can't even upgrade the mines.
You're just stuck in this one...
I'm not doing parkour for the second floor.
That's just a waste of time.
That's actually just a waste of time.
Keep working.
That's how they get you to work for the rest of your life.
You make barely below minimum wage.
So you always have to work.
You cannot stop.
I have to take three jobs just to get by.
I'm a farmer, a miner, and a lumberjack.
Just so I can make it work in Hello Kitty town.
The rent is insane.
But like, where else do I live?
Guys, either I live here or I live in the streets.
I don't know.
What is the exchange rate for gems?
And you would think gems is like a lot of money.
Because they're little gems.
But the gems exchange rate to one American dollar is like 500 gems to one American dollar.
It's nothing.
It's...
Hello Kitty fucked up the exchange rate.
She pumped up too many gems into the market.
So it means nothing.
It's like one Zimbabwean dollar.
One Zimbabwean dollar is like...
A trillion Zimbabwean dollars is like one US dollar.
That's how fucked up the exchange rate is now.
Oh, and what's up, Batsumaru plushie?
It's that good?
I thought it was a thousand for a dollar.
Welcome to international trade and economics.
She inflated her currency.
How much is it?
That's only 50!
Oh my god, that's fine.
I'm gonna sell my iron.
I can't.
Wait, is that like $40?
No.
Okay, fuck it.
I'm gonna sell iron.
I don't need it anymore.
I don't need it.
I'm almost there.
Wait, how much is this?
Okay, that's a lot.
That's enough.
Oh my god, it's $814.
Okay, we're almost there.
Okay, we gotta buy animal feed so I can make more.
The fact that the price is...
Oh my god.
And then, uh...
I'll buy more lettuce.
Okay.
And then, how much money do I have?
How much?
Okay, tomorrow is the spring festival.
Maybe I'll be happier.
I just need $1,500, Hello Kitty.
I just need...
Please, can I take a loan?
Miss Hello Kitty, please.
Just one loan.
Please, it's my dream.
It's my dream to have a cow.
Please, just one.
You know I'm good for it, Miss Kitty.
You know that.
I'm good for it.
No, it doesn't.
It just controls the page.
Oh, maybe I can fish.
Maybe I can fish.
There is no loan.
Go back to mine.
Miss Kitty, please.
Please, Miss Kitty.
I just need $1,000, Miss Kitty.
You know I can pay you back.
Please.
Maybe I can fish for food.
Fish for money.
Fishing for money.
Oh my god, my tin can.
My $1 tin can.
Oh look, I got a jar though.
So that means I don't have to buy jars at least.
Oh my god, it's literally just tin cans.
A dystopian nightmare.
Anything for a cow.
Oh, I was too late.
Wait, what?
What the fuck?
Why can't I catch anything?
I reeled it instantly.
Oh my god, you gotta be like...
Instant, instant.
That's so dumb.
Wait, what did I get?
I got an old tire.
Does that work?
Do old tires work for wheels?
Oh my god, I gotcha.
No, it's still polluted.
There is still...
There's nothing here anymore.
Hi from Indonesia.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Akoyuki, thank you for the super chat.
Oh my god, I'm just...
We're polluting this world.
Hellkitty's hiding something.
There's no fish in this.
These aren't even real fish.
All I've been fishing is just...
It's just algae, tires, and trash.
And jars.
Is there anything else?
Oh, I'm fucking...
I give up.
The truth is out there.
Doki, just keep fishing.
Uncover the truth.
This whole world is a lie, Doki.
Alright, what do I get?
Oh my god, a chiffon machine.
What do I get?
I got a chandelier.
Yay, I'm gonna sell this.
Wait, it's Kuromi's chandelier!
She touched it!
Okay, but how much is it?
Oh my...
I'm sorry, it's $800.
I'm sorry, I can't.
It's $800, guys.
I have to.
And then I'll give her algae.
And then...
I don't need all these jars.
How much is a jar?
It's not even that much.
Oh, fuck it.
I might as well...
I'll sell two.
I'll keep one of the jars for honey.
Alright, nice.
I'm almost there.
I'm almost there, guys.
You must break your adorable chain.
Kuromi would understand.
I'm in financial burden right now.
She'll understand that I sold a chandelier touched by Miss Kuromi.
She'll understand.
It's like when you're like in debt and you have to sell the TokiBird.
A TokiBird signed print.
And you're like...
But I won't.
I won't understand.
You're dead to me.
I signed that print with my own hands.
You're dead to me if you sell my merch.
If you sold merch that you bought.
I won't be understanding like Kuromi.
Wait, have I fed them yet?
I'll figure it out tomorrow.
If I fed them.
Alright, tomorrow is the Spring Festival.
Exactly.
My presents will keep you warm.
Oh my god, $600.
It's just $600.
$600 left.
And then, it'll be 5.
It's raining in the Spring Festival?
What kind of fucked up world is this?
Oh my god, today is the Spring Festival.
And it's raining.
I'm gonna sell my cat.
I'm desperate.
Oh no, it's sunny.
Yay!
It's sunny.
Don't worry.
Harvest, harvest.
I should have enough now.
If I'm mine today, I should have enough.
And if I sell a child.
Alright.
Thank you, thank you.
How do you still not have fucking hair yet?
Alright, get over here, chicken.
Oh my god, is that two chicken eggs?
Alright, who am I selling here?
Speaking of Hello Kitty, what type of pledge do you have?
Like collecting.
I remember back from the day that you have a decent collection.
But don't remember much more than that.
Mostly Kuromi and...
It'll be Kuromi and Hapamonpuren.
And Tsunomoto.
Alright, who's child am I selling?
Oh shit, I just remembered the pull list.
Thanks, Jarhods.
Thanks, go back to the factory now.
Alright.
Alright, who is it?
Oh, alright, eggs.
Who's going to the corporate?
Who's gonna work for your corporate over there?
You have been born to be sold.
Alright, I think like if I mine a little bit more today.
I should be able to afford...
I should be able to afford a cow.
Egggoons.
It's time, egggoon.
It's time.
It's time to go to the factory.
Where are my egggies at?
Where are you?
You have been born.
You have been chosen.
Oh my god.
You have been chosen to do something wonderful today.
For a wonderful, glorious leader.
Hello, kitty.
Alright, you're working for Pizza Hut.
That's alright.
Oh, Tan.
Hello, Tan.
Oh my god.
I hope you have fun.
Tan.
Alright.
It's time.
You have been born to do something very special today.
You have been born to give me a...
To be part of the cow funds.
No, don't.
No, I don't take tomatoes.
I only take eggs.
No volunteers here.
You can't volunteer yourself.
You're just a little tomato.
You haven't grown to be an egg yet.
Goodbye, Tan.
Get ready to serve Hello Kitty.
For $50.
All I got was $50.
That's okay.
Just $1 closer to the cow.
$1 closer to the cow.
Oh hey, what does that bitch Melody has to say?
Blueprints are a big investment, but they allow you to have a bigger and better house.
Imagine all that space for decorating.
That's it?
That's all she's gonna say to me?
Kotoki, why?
You know why.
It's all for the cow.
Goodbye, Tan.
My $50, Tan.
And that should be almost there.
Oh, there you go!
I don't even need to sell you for the cow!
Goodbye.
Yeah!
I got a cow!
I did it!
Alright, let's go to the festival.
What is there at the spring festival?
I understand she wants to talk to me, but she also doesn't want to talk to me?
Welcome to the spring festival.
How do I participate in it?
How do I participate in the spring festival?
I don't understand.
Is it time yet?
Hello?
Miss Kitty, how do I participate?
Have you tried a capsule machine?
Okay, guys.
Hello?
My melody won't even talk to me!
I'm sorry!
I shouldn't be the Kaguya bitch!
Who get the pass today?
Okay, I'm gonna go break into this person's house.
And then...
And then get out.
I waited 8 days for this.
I...
It doesn't matter?
It doesn't...
I waited 8 days.
I've waited 8 days, Melody!
Where's my spring festival?
That's right!
Where is it?
Where's my spring festival?
Miss Melody, where is it?
Where is my spring festival?
I worked hard for this.
Where is it?
Where the fuck is my spring festival?
How do I celebrate spring?
Spring!
Sadness angry.
Sadness groovy.
How do I celebrate spring?
I'm so sad.
I worked so hard to be here.
I'm...
I'm so sad.
What can I do?
There is only...
What do I give them?
Do you want my tablet?
I have nothing.
I have food.
Do you want my tire?
What spring festival?
I worked so hard in the mud.
And I don't even get to celebrate spring?
What's the point?
I just...
I get to watch the others have fun?
It said spring festival.
I have a level one friendship.
I got got.
I actually got got.
I thought...
I worked so hard.
But it doesn't matter.
It's okay, I have my cow.
Look at him.
He's so cute.
Hello, cow.
Hello, there.
I sold two children for you.
Hello, my cow.
Hello, there.
That's my cow.
Hello, cow.
I sold two kids to get him.
Moo.
It only took me two children.
I thought I could end the playthrough.
By going to the spring festival.
And celebrating with my Oshi.
And my Kami Oshi.
And my backup Oshi.
When my main Oshi isn't online and streaming.
Then I guess I'll watch you.
Don't think I don't know.
I'm that Oshi for some of you guys.
Reality is often disappointing.
The...
The call of...
Paranoid.
I don't understand.
Why doesn't my Melody let me celebrate the spring festival?
No, no, that's not me.
No, Toki, no.
That's not me.
Oh, no.
Okay.
Maybe if I go to her house.
She'll like reset herself.
And then I can celebrate the spring festival.
Maybe if you can celebrate the spring festival in the cave.
Thank you.
Maybe I can reset her.
Okay, alright.
And then I'll come outside.
And then she should be reset, right?
She should be reset now, right?
Can I celebrate the spring festival now, Miss Melody?
Can I...
Can I be part of...
Can I be part of the team?
I... I don't understand!
Okay, guys.
I'm desperate.
Give me a sec.
I just...
I wanna... I wanna celebrate.
I wanna...
Please.
Thank you.
There's barely anyone living in this town.
Please.
Can I celebrate?
Why can't I be?
I'm waving.
Please, Melody.
Please.
I'm gonna wave.
I'm gonna...
Whoa!
Over here.
I'm clapping.
Can I be part of...
Please, I'm clapping.
I'm clapping.
Isn't this what you want?
Please.
Let me join.
I just wanna be part of the festival.
I wanna...
Why can't I...
I wanted to end the stream at the festival.
I can't.
Please don't make me go back to the mines.
Please.
Don't make me go back to the mines.
I don't understand.
I did everything you wanted, Hello Kitty.
I did... Hello, Hello Kitty.
I did everything you want.
What more?
I sold you my children.
What more do you want, Hello Kitty?
Why can't I join the festival?
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I managed to escape the birdies' authorities.
I'll now accomplish my mission from women, the corporal, the yellow men.
Stay tuned, dragons, and wish me luck.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Everybody's going home.
And I can't even celebrate the goddamn festival.
All I can do is watch.
What a fucked up day.
What a fucked up day today.
I worked so hard.
I got my cow.
I mined.
But I couldn't even enjoy the celebrations.
They won't even invite me to the celebration, guys.
I talked to her.
And all she says is I'd love to come by your farm.
You have a favorite crop?
I'd love to come by your farm.
Do you have a favorite crop?
Blueprints are a bit of investment.
I'd love to come by your farm.
It's night time.
The festival is over.
I wasn't even invited.
I wasn't invited.
Guys, I think she's lost it.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
What a fucked up way to end today's stream, guys.
What a fucked up way.
I had...
I had a wonderful corporate life in Hello Kitty town working for my glorious leader, Miss Kitty.
I can't wait to do this all over again, everyone.
As always, everybody stay hydrated.
Posture check.
Get up and move around to get that blood flowing.
And if you stay up for me, head to bed, cause you deserve it.
I'll see you guys next time, everybody.
Bye-bye, guys.
Bye-bye.